So as women, we know we live in a different reality than men do, right?
But this manifested the other day in such an interesting way.
So I was driving with my husband,
and we are parking at this big box store with a big parking lot,
and he likes to park super far away,
as far away from anyone else as possible,
as far away from the front door as possible.
And I was huffing and puffing.
I'm like, ugh,
you always do this? You always park so far away.
And he's like, yeah.
He's like, I don't want the car to get messed up.
He goes, but you always park so close to other people.
Why do you do that? And I was like,
oh my god. He doesn't know.
He was like,
is it because you have short little legs and you don't wanna walk?
And I'm like, no,
it's so I don't get kidnapped.
And he thought I was crazy.
He thinks it's just me. And I was like, no.
A lot of women do this. Will park either close to the front,
close to the cart return, or under a light.
I'm like, for visibility.
Cause although your priority is the car not getting dinged,
mine is not getting kidnapped.
And I feel like those are different levels of concern.